body
and uh welcome to the third day of the
workshop we're delighted to have a team
ralph garden from hollywood university
uh starting the day
tim of course is an expert of
algorithmic game theory that needs no
introduction he has done similar work in
uh in this area and written
some of the most influential textbooks
and today he'll be talking about
aggregating conflicting forecasts thank
you so much tim
all right thanks very much for the for
the intro george appreciate it um also
thanks to all of the organizers for the
invitation to speak very happy to be
participating
and also very sorry i can't be out there
in person i know there's sort of a lot
of old friends of mine i haven't seen in
a while out there so wait um we'll get
to catch up soon
uh in any case what i wanted to tell you
about this morning
uh some joint work i've been doing with
my phd student um eric neyman um
and it's going to be called aggregating
conflicting forecasts
um this is drawn from a ec paper from
last year as well as two papers that are
under submission um i say joint work
here on the slide honestly that's being
like way too generous to myself um
what's actually been happening is sort
of eric has you know almost
single-handedly like a force of nature
been developing this kind of amazing
theory he likes to call algorithmic
epistemology and so this talk is
basically going to be sort of curated
highlights of a subset of his work not
all of his work connects very strongly
to machine learning theory but some of
it does
and that'll naturally be the part that
i'm that i'm highlighting today
all right so i know there's already been
a couple talks about sort of forecast
calibrations etc this week but i really
don't want to make any assumptions so
let me just start at the beginning right
so aggregating forecast what does that
mean
what's a forecast mathematically a
forecast is just a probability
distribution over some space of things
that could happen
simplest possible case which is still
very interesting is where you just have
two possible outcomes something either
happens or it doesn't it either rains
this weekend or it doesn't rain this
weekend
and we're going to be interpreting these
distributions as predictions right so a
meteorologist who says a 40 chance of
rain we identify that with a
distribution 0.4
comma 0.6
now in machine learning especially
supervised machine learning you know we
think about predictions all the time
obviously we often interpret the outputs
of models as predictions in that sense
for this talk i i think it'll be extra
meaningful if you also think about
examples of predictions you see on the
news every day
um you know so something like the
outcome of some election you know or
whether taking some action will lead to
military escalation for example
all right so aggregating forecast
suggests there are multiple forecasts so
that's what i'm going to be interested
in okay either because there's different
people using different models or there's
just different experts with different
opinions we're going to be looking at
when you have multiple generally
non-agreeing predictions about um the
same outcome
right so you know maybe you check two
different weather apps right one of them
says 40 chance of rain one of them says
70 chance of rain
um you know 538 i'm sure many of you
know sort of uses a bunch of different
polls that in general are making
different predictions about about the
election
um and you know whenever you have you
know in this event like so if you're a
decision maker and you've solicited
predictions from multiple sources and
you get conflicting signals there's a
question of what should you do is there
some reason to believe one expert more
than another is there some sensible way
to interpolate or sort of aggregate
the forecast into a single one and one
seed i want to plant sort of right here
on slide one is that sort of the right
way to solve this
problem the right way to do forecast
aggregation it may well depend on
aspects of the application that you're
looking at
so if you're just planning your kids
birthday party this weekend
right and one the weather app says you
know five percent chance of rain one
says point five percent chance of rain
you kind of don't really care that
there's a fact or ten difference or
you're like whatever i'm just going to
play in the birthday party for outside
sounds like it's going to work out
if you're talking about you know
estimating the probability of military
escalation the fact that you know one of
two military experts said five percent
even though the other one said point
five percent right that might you might
you know you might interpret that
information differently than you would
just for planning a birthday party okay
so that'll show up in the later when we
talk about the choice of a loss function
right so we want to aggregate forecasts
perhaps it depends on some aspects of
the setting but in any case we want to
reason about you know principled ways of
doing this
and one thing i want a theme to look out
for in this talk is we're going to be
taking what i think of as a very kind of
computer sciencey uh approach to this
problem in the sense that we're going to
want to basically minimize our
informational assumptions
subject to having a theory that gives us
interesting advice about how to do
forecast aggregation so what we will not
be doing is assuming some like joint
joint distribution over everything that
is common knowledge to the decision
makers and all the experts up front okay
that's the thing we don't want to do we
want aggregation methods that are kind
of robust not you know sort of
distribution
free and so those of you familiar with
the literature on prior free or prior
independent auctions you're kind of a
computer sciency alternative take uh
that favors robustness over optimality
compared to traditional auction theory
you might see some vague analogies with
the stuff i'm going to talk about today
all right so how do we aggregate
um well so the object of study is going
to be an aggregation method which just
takes as input a bunch of forecasts and
spits out as output a single forecast
the aggregate
what might an aggregation method look
like well maybe the very first thing
you'd think of is you average if one
weather app says 40 chance of rain
another one says 70 chance of rain you
say well i'm going to interpret that as
an aggregate prediction of 55
percent okay so that's just averaging
the forecasts this is also known as
linear
pooling an obvious extension if you have
some reason to trust some experts more
than others would be to have weighted
averaging so here you associate the
experts with non-negative weights
summing to one and instead of a regular
average you take a you take a weighted
average
what else could you do actually there's
a lot of other things you could do let
me mention what's probably the second
most well studied um way of aggregation
in this context
which is called logarithmic cooling
and basically the idea here is you take
i should have said as far as the
notation so um when you see linear
pooling
p star that's a vector indexed by
outcomes indexed by capital x okay
that's probability distribution uh i
here refers to one of the experts okay
so p sub i is the forecast of expert i
so that again is a is a vector indexed
by by capital x
all right so logarithmic cooling here
basically you're going to do an
arithmetic a geometric mean instead of
an arithmetic mean because you look at
the products the probabilities
rather than the sum
and again it's quite straightforward to
add weights if you wanted to to you know
to treat um some forecast is more
important than others then you would
just do this
corresponding weighted geometric mean
averaging and weighted averaging i'm
sure strikes everybody is supernatural
in case logarithmic pooling structure is
at all sort of unnatural um let me
mention that there is sort of i mean in
addition to just people have used it i
mean it's just there's also work that
justifies it in various ways so there's
certain bayesian settings where it
actually is sort of in some sense the
right thing to do um you can also
characterize logarithmic cooling as the
as the forecast which minimizes the
average tail divergence
um
uh with respect to the report with
respect to the pis with respect to the
and expert forecasts
so you know i mentioned weights in
passing here like it's trivial to add
them to these two specific examples
actually the expert weights are going to
be a super important thing that we focus
on for a lot of the talk so let's go
ahead and make the expert weights of
first order objects so now an
aggregation method is not a function
just from forecasts but from forecasts
along with weights for the experts and
its job is to compile all of that
information down into a single aggregate
forecast okay so that's what we mean by
an aggregation method we would like a
theory that tells us when we might want
to use one aggregation method rather
than another
all right so to have such a theory we
need some notion of like how good
a forecast is okay like the performance
of an aggregation method as per the
accuracy of its of its output of its
forecast
and because we're taking this sort of
hardcore non-bayesian approach right we
don't have a prior right we can't really
talk about the ex-ante performance of a
forecast it's going to depend on which
outcome is realized whether or not it
rains this weekend
so we can really only talk about sort of
the x-post accuracy
of any forecast in particular of an
aggregate
and so the way we're going to quantify
accuracy x post is using a loss function
okay so capital l takes two arguments p
here is a forecast so p is a probability
distribution uh over x over outcomes and
j is a specific outcome the outcome that
was actually realized
intuitively right so if you put a lot of
probability on the outcome that actually
happens your law should be small if you
put very little probability in your
forecast on the outcome that actually
happened your loss should be high you
kind of screwed up at least that's how
it looks x post
at this audience i think we'll be plenty
familiar with lots of different loss
functions you might use i'm going to
mention two
first one squared loss so this basically
you just take the forecast and you take
the standard basis vector for the
realized outcome and you look at the
squared um euclidean distance between
the two
so that's a very uh sort of standard
loss function
uh another very standard one would be
log loss so here the loss is going to
depend only on the probability you
assigned
um to the actual realized outcome j
and it's going to be the logarithm of
the reciprocal of whatever probability
you assigned to it
you'll notice that for you know this so
the best possible scenario for you is
that you you you predicted with a
hundred percent you predicted with 100
probability that j was going to happen
and then j did happen in that case you
can check you get zero loss in each of
these cases
the worst possible forecast is where you
deterministically predict some outcome
other than the one that actually happens
um in that case the loss you know of the
squared loss is going to be two and the
log loss is actually going to be
infinite so you'll notice that you know
as the as the forecast um
the probability of the realized outcome
goes to zero the log loss is blowing up
to infinity which eventually will be an
interesting uh distinction if you like
you can take outline transformations of
these loss functions it really doesn't
change anything for example if you want
to rescale the squared loss um feel free
to do that
so we're going to want a theory that's
pretty agnostic as to the loss function
so that sort of gives good advice
simultaneously across lots of different
loss functions you might use
the one thing i will always be assuming
is that the loss function is what's
known as a proper loss function of which
squared and log loss are two examples
what is proper mean it just means that
if there's something to learn like the
optimal strategy is to learn it okay so
if if there actually were some true
distribution
from which the outcome was sampled and
again we are not assuming that that's
the case but it's just a condition on a
loss function
if it so happens there really is a
distribution from which the outcome is
drawn well the loss minimizing forecast
you would think you would like it to be
the accurate one okay the one from which
the outcome really is being drawn and
that's the definition of a proper loss
function okay so the expected loss
minimizing forecast
is the accurate one any inaccurate
forecast will only get you um higher
loss if those of you familiar with the
theory of strictly proper scoring rules
this is really the same thing just
multiplied by
by minus one okay
all right
so that's uh sort of the basics
hopefully you understand what i mean by
the words in the title forecasts
aggregation methods loss functions
in this next part i want to really kind
of uh spell out the exact learning
problem that i want to study in detail
okay which is going to be the online
learning of weights for the experts who
are submitting the forecasts
now
there's kind of a lot of parameters
we've talked about thus far in fact
there's really actually kind of five if
you think about it and so i want to give
you a mental model how to think about
these five different ingredients right
we've got the loss function we've got
the aggregation method
we've got expert weights we've got
we've got expert forecasts and then we
have the eventual realized outcome okay
so those are the five things
i want you to think about like someone
chose the aggregation method chi for us
in advance okay so at least for now i
think if someone told us we're going to
be using linear pool or someone told us
we're going to be using logarithmic
pooling okay and that's not we don't
have an option to change that for the
moment
we do have control over the expert
weights right so if we have reason to
believe
we should pay more attention to some of
the forecasts than the other then we're
free to sort of express that in weights
that we're going to feed into the
aggregation method remember an
aggregation method takes up both weights
and it takes the forecasts
the forecasts we're going to be thinking
of as chosen by an adversary okay so
they can be just like whatever we don't
know okay
and at least initially we're also going
to give the adversary full control over
the realized outcome j okay
uh toward the end of the talk if there's
time we'll talk about a more restricted
adversary in which the outcome has to be
in some way related to the expert
forecast that the adversary also got to
choose okay
and so now you see so once we have all
these ingredients we can talk about the
loss of an aggregation method on a
particular realized outcome right so the
aggregation method takes as input the
weights from the top the forecast from
the side by definition it spits out an
aggregate forecast which i'm calling p
star when the adversary picks an outcome
j where some realized loss okay so those
are the those are the five ingredients
kai think of as chosen in advance l
think of as chosen in advance the pi's
and the j think of as chosen by an
adversary the weights think of as chosen
by an algorithm okay
so
with that set up we're going to be using
what i think is the sort of obvious
online learning problem you might state
at this point if you're familiar with
sort of just
kind of typical online learning problems
and regret minimization okay
we're going to think of the loss
function and aggregation method ellen
chi fixed in advance
once and for all
and then things will play out over time
steps okay where basically our learning
algorithm makes a decision and then the
adversary sort of chooses something we
suffer a loss and we move on okay
like i said the only thing under our
control is going to be the expert
weights so at time t the learning
algorithm has to choose some value for
the weights presumably based on sort of
past performance of the various experts
and then the adversary chooses
everything else so the adversary gets to
pick the expert forecasts so those
inputs to the aggregation method so now
that the weights have been fixed and the
forecasts have been fixed the aggregate
forecast p star for time t uh has been
forced and then the adversary gets to
pick the realized outcome uh and then
the learning algorithm suffers uh
suffers whatever loss okay the loss with
respect to the ah priori chosen loss
function capital l the output p star of
the aggregation method at this time step
given the weights that were chosen by
the learning algorithm and given the
outcome j chosen at this time step by
the adversary okay
so that's the online learning setup
and now what do we want what makes for a
good learning algorithm
under what conditions do we say we
picked the weights well
well obviously we'd like the total loss
to be small right that's that's how
we're measuring accuracy or performance
and we suffer loss every time step we'd
like the sum of the losses to be as
small as possible
but small relative to what like if the
total loss is 117 is that good is that
bad
um and so as usual in online learning
we're going to take as our benchmark
kind of the best uh fixed um strategy in
hindsight
so here in hindsight means all capital t
time steps have elapsed
everybody's seen the adversary's choices
okay so the expert forecast you know
that it picked at each time step the
realized outcome the depiction each time
step
given the forecasts and outcomes that
the adversary chose there will be some
weight vector w extra weight vector w
that among all weight vectors minimizes
the total loss okay
that's going to be our benchmark and
regret is just the extent to which
our total loss is higher than that
benchmark so if our total loss is 117
and the benchmark is 97
then our regret would be 20.
here's that exact same expression in
math
the first term is the total loss
incurred by our learning algorithm
over the capital t time steps the second
term
is just the minimum possible total loss
achievable
by a fixed weight vector in hindsight
given the adversaries choices okay
and the traditional goal which we'll
adopt here as well is we would like
regret to grow sublinearly in capital t
so if you think about sort of on a per
ton sp per time step basis
the per times step regret we're
suffering on average should be going to
zero as we get more and more experience
as capital t gets gets bigger and bigger
okay
and
so that's a learning problem
ellen kai are fixed up front adversary
gets to pick the p's um and the j and
our learning algorithms playing around
with the weights
but actually if you think about it it's
not it's not just a learning problem
it's really like a family of learning
problems indexed by two seemingly
different things okay index on the one
hand by a loss function l
you know squared loss log loss whatever
indexed also by an aggregation method
chi okay averaging log pooling whatever
for each choice of l and chi you get
uh you get an instantiation of this
learning problem
and it's totally conceivable that maybe
you know it's a solvable problem for
some choices of l and thai and it's not
a solvable problem meaning you can't get
subliminal regret for other choices of l
and chi okay so we want to understand
that better
we can think about this you know we can
study this problem either sort of in at
a general level or a specific level so
we can ask generally what properties of
a loss function and aggregation method
allow there to be online learning
algorithms with sublinear regret and
we'll do that first if there's time
we'll say a little bit about a specific
case of a specific l and chi that we
really care about namely log loss and
logarithmic pooling okay
so that is the learning problem um that
we're really going to focus on and uh
one more thing i want to say in this
part of the talk i want to i want to
suggest what property it seems yeah i
want to suggest a property that's you
know seems in some sense necessary to
have nice learning results okay which is
a a convexity property okay
so we'd like to regret to be sublinear
in t
um whether or not we can do that may
depend on ellen kai
and i claim it's very natural to focus
on choices of loss functions and
aggregation methods
such that you get convexity in in the
weights okay so again remember there's
five ingredients in this model so let's
fix all four for the four of them that
are not the weights so the loss function
l the aggregation method chi those are
chosen in advance let's think about
fixed choices for the expert forecasts
let's think about a fixed realized
outcome j
the free remaining parameters are the
expert weights so we can talk about the
loss as a function of the weights with
everything else fixed
uh that
we would like to be convex a convex
function okay in the weight vector no
matter what the p is no matter what the
j is
why do i say that you know why do i say
convexity seems important well you know
just you know look look at the top look
at the definition of regret and look at
that second term
look at that benchmark
best weight vector in hindsight right
that's minimizing the sum of these
capital ls
if the capital l's are guaranteed to be
convex and the weights that's just
minimizing a condex function that's
something you can do efficiently
in um you know using for example the
ellipsoid method or even you know
gradient descent depending on what kinds
of guarantees you want
if capital l is not convex
then even just something as simple as
computing the benchmark typically is
going to be an empty hard problem so if
we want kind of online learning
arguments that are nice either in the
sense of polynomial time
or in the sense that they only use kind
of basic machinery like first order
methods
it seems like you would really need
these capital ls to be convex in the
weights
you could imagine doing something more
general and just looking you know
studying non-convex functions also and
ask about oracle efficiency results
where i give you sort of a sub routine
that i promised for you will solve this
sort of problem on the right we did not
look at that okay so we really wanted
sort of genuinely efficient algorithms
in the traditional sense we wanted
simple learning algorithms and so for
that you know given those goals it
seemed like we had to focus on pairs of
loss functions and aggregation methods
that have this conducivity property so
that the loss holding everything else
fixed in the weights
is a convex function so the question i
now want to ask is you know for so we
want to ask the question for which loss
functions l and which aggregation
methods chi can we have a good online
learning algorithm meaning sublinear
regret
now i'm saying let's also want an
efficient one and let's sort of identify
that with convexity and so now the
question reduces to for what cases of l
and chi
is this is this loss function convex in
the weights okay
so let me pause here to see if there's
any questions right so what have we done
i've told you some of the basic
vocabulary and i've specified fully uh
the online learning problem that i care
about so if the online learning problem
that i want to solve is not clear you
should definitely speak up the other
thing i've done is highlighted this
complexity property it seems like we
want and the next part of the talk will
understand when it is that we get that
convexity properly
tim have you thought about um
the pooling method itself changing
like giving algor the algorithm the
ability to change how
change kai
uh we have and in fact eric and i were
just talking about that earlier this
week um and we think we need to verify
this but we think it's just like for
example you have a constant number of
different um sort of methods that you're
looking at and you know how to sort of
do regret minimization for each of them
you should be able to also then kind of
have a top level online learning
algorithm that sort of figures out which
of the k methods is the best one to use
that so we haven't proved that i mean
it's kind of a conjecture but you know
based on the proofs that we have so far
we suspect um that would work out does
that make sense
yes
[Music]
hey tim a follow-up question which is uh
so if it's not a constant number that
you're thinking about but somehow this
entire problem is maybe like the
the pooling is somehow parametrized
right i know the weights are already a
parameter but if you think of like
somehow the pooling method can be
parametrized in some way would convexity
with respect to however that
parameterizing happens also be
sufficient
yeah it's a good question jim i would
you think maybe yes i don't know
let me answer it in a different way
which is
exactly the point of this next part of
the talk
is that given the loss function there's
really one aggregation method you should
use so in some sense
what i'm going to show you next is the
choice of the loss function i always say
it forces the aggregation method but the
whole point of the theory i'll describe
in this third part
is trying to justify you know that
really the loss function fits is the
method you should be thinking about so
the only remaining task is then to
understand what the weight should be
make sense thanks yeah
it's great questions
all right great so hopefully everybody's
clear also the online learning problem
we want to
for a fixed aggregation method fixed
loss function we want to learn sort of
the best weights we want convexity and
the loss with respect to the weights
when do we get that okay
well
um how do we how do we get a feel for
this question well we can first look at
it just in the cases that we know right
i've given you two examples of
aggregation methods linear pooling and
logarithmic cooling i've given you two
examples of proper loss functions
squared loss and log loss that gives us
four combinations we can ask for each of
those four is it the case
that this loss is guaranteed to be a
convex function of the weights okay
and so let's just fill in this matrix um
clockwise uh i'm not going to go through
the algebra but none of these are
particularly hard to to show
maybe the simplest case simply you know
the first thing to try squared loss and
just averaging you might expect that to
be a particularly nice case and indeed
you do get convexity in the weights in
that case
interestingly if you switch if you
actually look at the way you can prove
it for squared loss the only thing you
really need to fill in a yes in the
upper left
uh all you need is that it's linear
pooling plus a convex loss function okay
convexity is kind of all you need to
push that argument through
log loss is a convex function then also
when coupled with linear pooling will
give you the convexity and capital l
with respect to the weights
uh you might hope that the two logs sort
of play nicely together and indeed they
do so log loss combined with logarithmic
cooling um
gives you condensing the weights at this
point maybe you think everything
reasonable would give you condensity in
the weights but in fact
if you combine logarithmic cooling with
the squared loss function this term on
the top of the slide is not generally
convex in the weights
so this means there's something we have
to understand right we actually have to
understand under what conditions do we
have condensable under what assumptions
about the loss function and the
aggregation method
so what would be some again this is this
is a
ridiculous interpolation from a tiny
number of data points but if we just
wanted to look at the pattern of the
yeses here
what could be going on maybe there's
something special about the first row we
had all the guesses there maybe there's
something special in the second column
or maybe there's something special about
the diagonal right in the two by two
matrix there's only there's a lot of
hypotheses you can generate
so um is there something special about
the first row sort of right like i
mentioned that with linear pooling all
you need is for the loss function to be
convex
now a loss function being proper does
not imply that a loss function is convex
however it is true that all of those
sort of most popular or almost all at
least to the most popular proper loss
functions are convex so you would get a
lot of yeses in this first row okay
it turns out um if you play around with
it there's really nothing special about
the second column okay the yes in the
upper right is explained by the choice
of linear pooling it's not explained by
the choice of log loss if you added a
bunch of rows you get a lot of no's in
that second column
but what's really interesting and the
point of this part of the talk is
actually there is really something
special about the diagonal what do i
mean by that i mean there's basically
going to be an infinite number of rows
and an infinite number of columns and so
there's going to be a way to enumerate
aggregation methods and enumerate proper
loss functions so that you get yeses all
along the diagonal and that'll be the
association between loss functions and
aggregation methods that i mentioned
so
and this is now getting into the ec
paper from from last year
you know
the choice of the loss function right
that may reflect the application right
we talked about you know whether or not
you're planning your kids birthday party
you may have different ways of thinking
about probabilities than when you're
thinking about sort of military
escalation and so in particular you know
if you're really concerned about
probabilities around zero right you
might want to use sort of the log loss
function because that's the one that
blows up as the probability gets close
to zero if you have more kind of uniform
preferences in some sense over different
probabilities you know maybe the the
squared loss function makes more sense
so for us you know when we talked about
forecast aggregation depending on
properties of the application
all of the application specific stuff
we're going to assume that gets rolled
up into the choice of which proper loss
function you use so stare at your
application
decide how you feel about the relative
importance of different probabilities
and then based on that choose a proper
loss function
now what would be really nice is if
that's all the application specific work
you had to do okay once you have it once
you have the loss function the
application that's that same reasoning
also told you which aggregation method
chi you should be using
and that's exactly kind of the main
results of the ec paper so the each
proper loss function capital l
uh we you know we define a corresponding
aggregation method chi sub l that
satisfies a number of nice properties
this is obviously an informal statement
but this again is like maybe the sort of
central part of talk so i will take time
to tell you exactly what this
correspondence looked like and what
these nice properties are one of those
nice properties will be the conductivity
property that we've been after um from
the learning problem
all right so before i tell you the um
exact definition
you know what's the idea the idea i
think is pretty natural in a way right
so so what does an aggregation method do
right it takes as input weights and
forecasts and it's supposed to output
some kind of consensus or some kind of
compromise between the forecasts
so intuitively you want you know it
seems like you want some kind of center
of center of mass right of the expert
forecast right this for forecasts are
all kind of points in the simplex you
know you kind of want some center of
mass in the middle of all of them right
but as we said
you know that notion of center of mass
should somehow depend on the choice of
the loss function because we said the
loss function is what encodes what's
special about the application and we
have intuition that details of the
application may influence how you want
to do the aggregation
all right
so what's the simplest way we could
carry that out
well we could say you know let's go
ahead and choose kind of the the
aggregate forecast um you know as
something that minimizes the average
distance okay to all of the expert
forecasts in that sense it's sort of a
compromise okay i guess the experts have
weights too so let's say minimize
weighted average distance
um where the distance notion should be
dependent on the loss function okay
so your choice of loss function will
determine the distance notion but then
given that distance notion all of these
chi sub l's look exactly the same they
just minimize the weighted average
distance um to the reported forecast
where again the weights or the given
expert weights uh for the for the um
given to the aggregation method
now i'm gonna i'm gonna give you the
exact formula here on the slide one it's
my guess is at least a few people in
this crowd kind of eat bregman
divergences for breakfast
so if you identify with that crowd
you'll look at this and you'll be like
dude this is just like a suitable
bregman divergence and you're right okay
it is it's uh the bregman divergence of
what's known as the savage
representation of a proper loss function
we don't need any of that stuff okay so
if you've never heard of that stuff
don't worry about it i'm just going to
show you the formulas which you know i
think are pretty natural just just
staring at them from first principles
all right so um i'm going to find this
distance notion i need to warn you it's
asymmetric okay so the distance between
from p to q and from q to p they're
going to be different
uh and so let's start with the second
term okay so the the second term um says
the following it says suppose reality
is that the outcome the realized outcome
is chosen from some distribution p okay
again that's not an assumption you know
in our model but for the purposes of
interpreting this term
imagine that there's some true
distribution p governing the outcome
and then we imagine an accurate forecast
and we look at the expected loss
that you would suffer okay expected over
the random choice of outcome from the
assumed distribution p
okay expected loss of an accurate
forecast when reality is p
now by virtue of capital l being proper
right
that's as small as this term can get
remember proper loss function means you
minimize expected loss with an accurate
forecast
so the first term is going to be
expected loss when reality is p but the
forecast q is inaccurate
and because capital l is proper this
will be an only bigger term than the
second one and this difference will be
non-negative
so that's our distance notion the d sub
l p q where l is the loss function it's
the extent to which your expected loss
is higher with an inaccurate forecast of
q
relative to an accurate forecast of p
that is how we measure sort of
you know how you know how much in some
sense how how much of a compromise is
needed to
to use q instead of p
all right so here's that exact same
definition again
and now our association is going to be
exactly what i promised okay so we call
this the qa pooling method chi sub l
corresponding to the proper loss
function l q a here stands for quasi-or
quasi-arithmetic
uh and so given this distance notion up
at the top we just look you know we just
the method just outputs the consensus
forecast p star meaning the forecast
that minimizes the weighted average
distance to the pi's
where the weight in that weighted
average or just the expert weights
provided to the provided to the method
okay so in effects right you have all
these experts they've got like the way
to think about it is you have and
experts they all have like wrong beliefs
in some sense
and so you're trying to basically say
which version of reality
would make all of these experts feel
kind of least bad about themselves right
would suffer kind of like the least
additional expected loss
relative to if they had submitted
accurate forecasts okay
so that's the definition all right
it actually seems like reasonably
natural right it's kind of like a loss
function dependent notion of the center
of mass i'm not saying it's like the
first thing you'd write down necessarily
but i hope it doesn't sound totally
crazy um and indeed as it turns out has
a lot of really nice mathematical
properties i'll detail those on the next
slide for now just because i'm sure some
of you are wondering uh let me say that
this is in fact well defined okay
meaning that this argument this minimum
this minimization is attained and it's
attained uh uniquely the reason that's
true this is really where we're using
the assumption that the loss function is
proper um that gives you the fact that
the sum on the right hand side is convex
in its first argument
conducts and what you're minimizing over
p star so that means there's going to be
a unique minimizer for that right hand
side and so chi sub l really is well
defined whatever your proper loss
function may be
all right let me pause for questions
real quick because this is really in
some ways this is the it's a little bit
technical but in some ways this is the
you know of technical statements this is
maybe the one i want you to remember out
of the entire talk so
anything i can clarify at this point
um so these w i's earlier were
the parameters that defined p star but
now there's some kind of weights
on the experts and p star is
not directly dependent on w i's it's not
like a linear combination
uh that's correct so in linear pooling
linear pooling is exactly where p star
is the linear combination of the pis
and we'll talk about when linear pooling
is justified but sometimes it's not and
if you're not doing linear pooling
then p star is a more complicated
function of the pis
than just a linear combination
specifically it's the it's the solution
to this minimization problem on the
right hand side
so i guess what's confusing me is that
where do these wis come from like we
were earlier learning them right so
yeah so remember so so in the second
part of the talk we have the learning
problem and there the goal was to figure
out the right weights
then at the end of part two we said like
oh as a prerequisite for having nice
online learning algorithms like like
polynomial time ones
it seems like we need this analytic
property which is convexity of capital l
in w holding everything else fixed so in
this part of the talk we're setting
aside the learning problems and we're
just focusing on this analytic condition
asking when does it hold
once we have a satisfactory answer to
that question we'll return to the
learning problem and make you know take
advantage of the conduct so you haven't
just proved does that make sense
yeah
thanks right just a quick question when
you say um proper do you mean strictly
proper for the uniqueness that you're
talking about yep
yep strictly proper so so the um when
you know when reality is governed by p
star p star should be the unique report
so any inaccurate forecast should be
strictly penalized relative to an
accurate one
okay great questions
all right
so hopefully everyone now understands
this correspondence i talked about to
each proper loss function we get a
corresponding aggregation method where
it's it's aggregate forecast is defined
as the solution to this convex
minimization problem on the right hand
side of the blue equation
so it's well defined okay great that's
fine
but like it's i'm sure it stretches like
kind of abstract right so like a very
natural initial sanity check
would be like okay well we we have two
proper loss functions we've been talking
about right squared loss and log loss
why not just apply
this definition and see what the
corresponding qa pooling methods are
so first of all you can you can say well
suppose we take square loss this this i
think is not surprising um and then in
fact um you know you do want to do
averaging okay you do want to do linear
pooling uh if your loss function is
squared loss i think many of you would
have guessed that point
um a little bit more interesting i mean
something you kind of hoped it would be
true just based on like the the you know
syntactic similarity of these two
phrases log loss and log fooling
uh but it actually is true okay so if
you feed the the the log loss function
into um the qa into this sort of
correspondence you get back the
logarithmic cooling aggregation method
but you know more than either of these
separately i think what's really
interesting here is as far as we know
there was never right so so it's
definitely true that in aggregation
these are the two most commonly studied
loss functions these are the two most
commonly studied aggregation methods
and what we're saying here is there's a
natural pairing between the two
and moreover there's sort of a common
sort of explanation for why each of
those correspondences is what it is and
we're actually not aware of any other
sort of previous explanation that sort
of really
you know advocated this particular
pairing and certainly not one that kind
of gave a common reasoning that that
these correspondences should
simultaneously exist all right anyways
so when we so maybe this is just
historical when we saw this we got
excited
we were like oh wow the two most famous
loss functions go to the two most famous
aggregation methods maybe we're on to
something
and then you know we asked ourselves how
would we convince the world that we're
onto something right that anyone can
make it anyone can make a definition but
like why this one okay what kind of
evidence can we amass that we made the
right earth a good definition
so one thing we did is we we justified
it axiomatically okay
we said well look
you know we get all these you know we
get all these aggregation methods as qa
pools okay so imagine ranging over all
proper loss functions in the world and
then you get all corresponding qa
pooling methods so that gives you a big
old set of um of sort of aggregation
methods i should have said this there's
a lot of proper loss functions in the
world right so you know i'm mentioning
squared and log loss it's a huge space
there's sort of a correspondence between
proper loss functions and like convex
functions so there's kind of a lot of
them and so to each of those proper loss
functions you get an aggregation so
that's just like really big set
and we show that this set of aggregation
methods actually is also exactly the
same set of aggregation methods
that satisfies a particular list of six
axioms that we all feel are quite
natural okay
i want to emphasize these axioms do not
speak about any loss functions okay
they're not sort of thinking about a
case where you're doing loss
minimization the axioms are things like
as an operator the aggregation method
should be associated and commutative
right so like it should be it should be
a function only of the unordered set of
weighted of weight forecast pairs not of
like the specific names for example
so those are the those are the nature of
the axioms and what we show is that
these axioms actually define exactly the
same set that you would get ranging over
all proper loss functions and looking at
the corresponding qa pools okay so that
to us you know was a mathematical way of
saying that this feeling of aggregation
methods is in some sense seems like a
fundamental class
a lot of the axioms are kind of like
really simple like associativity and so
on one interesting one that we use is
item potence
and this may come up later if there's
time which just says if there's no
disagreements among the expert forecasts
you know there's no reason to do
anything else if all your weather apps
say 70 chance of rain you're like i
guess it's 70 chance of rain
interestingly there are
models different than this one where you
might actually want to break item
potentials okay but qa pooling always
satisfies importance and which is
appropriate when sort of different
experts come to the same forecast for
the same reasons in some sense okay
anyways
so that's an axiomatic justification of
our definition it defines sort of a set
of methods you can define in a totally
different way
we also give a sort of optimization type
justification saying that if you imagine
a decision maker wanting to solve a
certain min max optimization problem uh
in fact the right aggregation method to
use the optimal aggregation method to
use for sort of worst case loss in some
sense
would be the qa pool okay
i should say that this fourth one at
least our proof needs assumptions a
little bit beyond just the these are
assumptions on the loss function
assumptions a little bit beyond just the
loss function being proper
which is a little annoying the good news
is these minor conditions they certainly
hold for squared loss log loss almost
any proper loss function you'd care to
use uh they do not hold for every single
proper loss function um that said we
wouldn't be surprised if this statement
isn't that true for every proper loss
function but our proof needs a slight
extra technical condition
under that exact same sort of mild
technical condition we get exactly the
convexity property that we wanted so
this is what was important for our
learning application we said if we want
to use like gradient descent or some
other nice online learning algorithm it
seemed like holding all four ingredients
fixed other than the weights we wanted
the loss to be convex and weights and
whenever you look at the pairing between
a proper loss function
subject to this like monotonical
conditions and the corresponding qa
pooling method chi sub l
every such peering automatically gives
you the convexity you wanted and that's
what i meant by the diagonal of that
matrix being all yes's okay so the rows
are indexed by proper loss functions
with these minor extra technical
additions the columns are indexed by the
corresponding qa pooling methods and
this result says that the diagonal is
made up of nothing but yeses you have
convexity um all along the way okay
uh even though this is a very important
result for sort of the context of this
talk i'm not going to i'm not going to
prove it you know proofs of convexity
are usually either trivial or involve a
lot of turning the crank algebra
um this proof it's actually in some ways
a little bit in between but it's a
little bit more of the second one so i'm
going to spare you the the turning the
crank and i'm just going to just going
to um use this and and what comes next
okay so the the uh the emphasis of our
ec21 paper is really properties three
and four uh but what's really relevant
for the learning problem we're talking
about here is this is this property five
all right so any questions about qa
pooling before i now bring it back to
talking about regret minimization
okay good
so that was the longest and sort of most
technical part of the talk so i just
want to say a couple quicker things
in my remaining time
so first let's just you know tie things
together
let's go back to the learning problem
that we're interested in let's make use
of this complexity property as we'll see
convexity was the hard part the rest is
kind of taken care of by basically
off-the-shelf technology but i know it's
been like 20 minutes so let me just
remind you what was the learning problem
right so we're thinking of l and chi is
fixed up front
now we know we're probably thinking of a
loss function in the corresponding qa
pool chi sub l but in any case the
general learning problem
um you have you have ellen kai
fix once once and for all up front
uh things take place over time steps um
and each time step learning algorithm
goes first picks whatever expert weights
it wants presumably as a function of
past performance of those experts i mean
the adversary gets to pick everything
else adversary can pick um the forecast
and can also pick the outcome
um you know once the adversaries picked
the forecasts along with the choice of
the algorithm's weights that forces the
aggregate forecast p star then once you
have that adversarially chosen outcome j
you know what your loss is just the loss
function as a function of the aggregate
forecast and the realized outcome the
goal remember is to minimize regret
so our benchmark is sort of the minimum
total loss you could have achieved in
hindsight with a fixed expert weight
vector given the choices of the
adversary regret is the extent to which
our learning algorithm suffers more loss
than that
and we would like that to grow
sublinearly in the number of time steps
so the per time step regret should be
little of one
as capital t goes to infinity and as we
as we discussed we were sort of thinking
probably it mattered which which ellen
kai we were talking about
so
we now get sort of a very you know a
fairly general positive result for the
online learning of expert weights
in this setup okay so specifically you
know really kind of a direct application
of the complexity property that i left
you with in the previous part of the
talk
we get as a consequence just using
online gradient descent right so as sort
of first done by zinkovic um whenever
you have a loss function that's proper
okay proper plus this a little bit of
extra stuff
and for this slide a loss function that
is bounded we'll get back to that we'll
get back to that but for this slide a
loss function that is bounded whenever
you have such a loss function
and you use the corresponding qa pooling
method then in fact you will be able to
learn the right weights in the sense
that online gradient descent will
achieve sub-linear indeed square root of
capital t regret okay
and really though the hard part was was
getting the convexity okay once you have
the you know those of you who know a lot
about online learning know this knows
the convexity plays a really strong role
in it and there's tons of techniques to
do online convex optimization well again
really just that we literally like
version one of online grading to stand
from syncobitch already gives you the
sort of rooty regret bound for as long
as you're using the right aggregation
method chi sub l for this particular
loss function capital l
okay
all right
good
so that's just putting parts two and
three of the talk together part two was
what we wanted part three was sort of
the conducivity properties of qa pools
and now here we're seeing putting those
together we actually get what we want
sort of
we get what we want for bounded loss
functions right which lots of loss
functions are bounded you know squared
loss with plenty of others
but i have to concede
right i've only been using two running
examples of loss functions and only one
of the two satisfies boundedness right
the log loss function is not bounded and
so this theorem actually doesn't apply
so that's a little frustrating right one
of my two leading examples i actually
still don't have good online learning
results for so what's up with that let's
drill down on that next
and what we'll see is that actually um
for the log loss case and the
corresponding qa pooling method which is
logarithmic pooling we'll actually need
to restrict the adversary a little bit
uh and furthermore even under that
adversarial adversary restriction we're
going to have to work a little harder
but in the end we will be able to get
our vanishing regret results happily
okay
all right
obviously log loss is not bounded so
obviously at least as stated the theorem
for bounded loss functions does not
apply
but it gets worse actually which is that
the theorem's simply false in our
current model with our current sort of
uh notion of an adversary okay and i'm
talking here about um log loss with the
corresponding pooling method which is
logarithmic pooling
um and sort of the the basically what
goes really wrong okay the reason this
is the reason the theorem is false
is because the adversary at each time
step
right remember it gets to choose two
things right it gets to choose the
expert forecast the pi's
and it also gets to choose the outcome j
the realized outcome at that time step
okay and if you think about it there's
no coupling between those two things the
adversaries choose in our model thus far
right the realized outcome j
literally doesn't need to have any
relationship whatsoever okay for the
forecast reported by experts all the
forecasts could say 100 chance of rain
and the adversary can say you know sorry
you know um it didn't rain okay
and um so this coupled with the
unboundedness of log loss those two
things work in tandem to show that that
theorem on the previous slide is false
uh so basically you know if an adversary
you know you know um assigns if you have
two experts you know one expert says
something has basically zero probability
the other expert is kind of like neutral
50 50. turns out the log pool is going
to assign the event also very low
probability and then the adversary can
then just make that event happen and
boom the law totally blows up the
learning algorithm doesn't suffer
infinite loss but it suffers a really
really big amount of loss
so high level the point to take away
here is just that we've been working
with a super powerful adversary that is
not constrained to couple its realized
outcome to its chosen forecast at all
we were able to get away with it with
bounded loss functions we're not able to
get away with it with unbounded loss
functions okay we really have to pay the
price for that strong adversary model in
the log loss case
was there a question
okay
um
so
you know the obvious next step is to say
well let's restrict the adversary and
make it a little bit more reasonable
right we still want the adversary to be
able to do all kinds of crazy different
things
but you know
these are so-called experts right so it
seems like we should be able to insist
that the realized outcome has something
to do
with the forecasts of the experts okay
so formally we're going to be assuming
that the experts are what's known as
calibrated
some of you i think will know exactly
what that means um if you don't that's
totally fine i'll define it for you for
you now
so here's going to be our new
our new adversary which will be more
restricted than our old one but we'll
still have lots of degrees of freedom
let me describe it as sort of like a
semi-random model so kind of a hybrid of
a worst case and an average case model
so an adversary in nature will like
collaborate to sort of produce
kind of the input at a given time step
of our learning problem
so the adversary it's going to go first
and it's going to pick a joint
distribution over everything that the
adversary is in control of at a given
time step namely the n expert forecasts
and the realized outcome j so the
adversary says here's a joint
distribution over n plus one tuples okay
now we're not gonna let the adversary
pick whatever joint distribution it
wants again we want sort of the outcome
to have something to do with the
forecasts so this is the constraint we
insist on okay every expert is
calibrated what does that mean
that means if sort of as an outside
observer okay
if you see if the only thing you know
is that a particular expert i you know
had some forecast p okay so for example
right that particular outcome had one
percent probability in their forecast
and that's the only thing you know
then the probability over the remaining
randomness okay and the sample from this
joint distribution
uh the probability of this outcome
should be exactly what expert i forecast
it should be one percent okay so if the
only thing you know is that expert i
thinks outcome j is a one percent
probability then if you see that over
and over and over again only one in a
hundred times should you be seeing a
realized outcome of j
and that should be true for each of the
experts and for each of the possible
outcomes okay
so that's what i mean by every expert is
calibrated conditioned just on their
forecast you know in expectation over
the rest of the randomness their
forecast actually is accurate
in particular like whenever some
whenever an outcome is forecast to be
very unlikely it will in fact be
realized uh very infrequent
all right so this is where the adversary
goes first if it's whatever joint
distribution it wants subject to the
calibration constraints nature is then
the one who actually samples from this
joint distribution and it is that sam
nature sample that gets passed on to the
learning algorithm okay the learning
algorithm does not know okay that the
adversary does not know the adversary's
joint distribution um the algorithm
doesn't even know per se the joint
distribution satisfies calibration and
the analysis of our learning algorithm
we will of course appeal to the fact um
we will and analyze it in the case where
this joint distribution is calibrated
okay
all right so that's what i mean by
hybrid model adversary pixel joint
distribution subject to constraints
nature samples from that joint
distribution that's what gets passed on
to the learning out
now if you haven't seen this before it
may you may be wondering like okay like
have i just like totally painted the
adversary into a corner where they
basically can't do anything can they
just have to do very benign things
but let me emphasize you know this is a
non-trivial constraint calibration it'll
flip things from being not having
positive results to having positive
results but the adversary even subject
to calibration has tremendous
flexibility remain okay in particular it
really has tremendous control over the
correlation
between different um experts forecasts
maybe the easiest way to convince
yourself there's a lot of flexibility is
just to count the number of free
variables and the number of constraints
okay so the adversary is picking this
joint distribution over these n plus one
two poles right and really can specify
an arbitrary sort of probability of each
of those two poles
and so that's a number of free
parameters that's scaling exponentially
with the number of experts okay so
that's sort of how many free variables
the adversary has to work with
calibration imposes a number of
constraints linear constraints that is
merely linear in the number of in the
number of experts you have a decent
number of experts you've got a huge
dimensional space of possible joint
distributions that the adversary can
choose from all the while satisfying the
calibration required okay
so this is going to be our restricted
notion of an adversary fix a joint
distribution has to satisfy calibration
but nothing else
nature samples gets passed to the
learning algorithm everything else is as
before
and we show that actually calibration is
sufficient
to recover positive online learning
results for
log loss and as usual we're you know
coupled with the corresponding qa
pooling method
logarithmic pooling
in particular we show this for the
online gradient to send it turns out
does not work um
online mirror descent with the
appropriate choice of regularizer does
work in the sense that you get uh
sublinear regret specifically our bounds
give square root of t log t regret okay
so the bad example for log loss and
logarithmic pooling this shows that
really the only reason that example
could exist would be was because of the
unreasonable uncoupledness between the
adversary's choice of outcome and the
adversary's choice of expert forecasts
um
you're not going to say much about the
proof obviously at this late date
obviously we have to use the calibration
hypothesis okay otherwise this would be
false
basically that means that whenever the
logarithmic pool of the expert forecast
has low
assigns low probability of some outcome
that outcome is realized
rarely there's no way we're going to
prove a good point wise per time step of
rebound there may be the occasional time
step where you have a massive massive
amount of regret so we really need to
analyze the expectation expected regret
in a much more careful way there's kind
of this quantitative tug of war between
like you know the forces of you know the
forces of evil which is that you know
the closer extra probabilities are to
zero you know the bigger the loss you
might suffer is and then the forces of
good which is that all as probabilities
get close to zero the bad event is very
unlikely to happen and without doing the
algebra i don't know how you would know
which of these forces wins um as it
turns out if you use a frankly pretty
tricky in my opinion potential function
argument that eric came up with
you can prove that the forces of good
win and you do get sublinear sublinear
regret okay but this one this is not off
the shelf this one you really have to
work for
okay
all right good
uh i just want to say two minutes on one
topic uh and then i'll be done
i alluded at some point you know that
when we're talking about the axiomatic
characterization of qa cooling methods
that all of them satisfy item focus
meaning that if all of the inputs to the
aggregation method are exactly the same
forecast then the output of the
aggregation method is also going to be
that forecast if all your weather apps
say 70
your aggregate prediction is also going
to be 70
why would you ever not want to do this
well i claim you do want to do this if
somehow there's a common reason why
everybody's telling you the same number
if all the weather apps are using the
same climate model right and getting to
the same answer there's no reason to
kind of do anything different because
it's sort of redundant
however if different experts arrive at
potentially the same forecast but for
different reasons
based on you know for example
independent pieces of evidence
that actually motivates a technique
known as extremization okay where you
actually take the forecasts and you
actually move it closer to either zero
or one as appropriate okay
let me give an example
imagine there's some coin
and it has some bias okay and just we
have a prior the bias chosen uniformly
between zero and one and your job is to
guess the bias minimize squared loss if
you like
so knowing nothing other than the prior
you would say oh i guess my best guess
is that the bias is one half that would
minimize the that would minimize my
spread loss
on the other hand like think about an
expert who gets to flip the coin once
and sees heads
that expert is going to do a bayesian
updates and their new guess at the bias
is going to be two-thirds if you do the
simple arithmetic okay
but now imagine you're an aggregator
right and two different experts both
tell you
a probability of two that their guess is
two-thirds
and suppose they each they each saw a
different coin flip each of which came
up heads well now as the aggregator you
in effect have seen two coin flips that
have both gone up heads so when you do
your bayesian update you're gonna get an
even bigger number specifically you're
gonna get three quarters
so in this simple bayesian story even
though all of the forecasts are going to
be two-thirds
because the two-thirds are coming from
independent sources the optimal
aggregate is higher than that it's
three-quarters it's in that sense it's
more extreme um than just the common
value of all the expert uh forecasts
okay
um and so that's just sort of a toy
story about why this might come up why
it might be useful it's actually been
experimented with empirically and it is
actually quite useful in the sense that
if you sort of look at data sets and you
look at different aggregation methods
and you sort of score them according to
some loss function
often extermination will give you sort
of more accurate predictions than if you
didn't use it
and so one question in one of our papers
under submission is you know can you
have a robust theoretical justification
for extremization okay
and so the answer is yes um i don't i'm
basically running out of time but let me
just say a little bit about this
so if you think about it you know i
mentioned this whole talk we were making
minimal informational assumptions right
like no no priors no nothing nothing
bayesian at all
if you think about it to make sense of
extremization
you kind of need a prior right because
you kind of need to know the forecast
you're getting from experts are they
higher than you expected or lower than
you expected okay in the former case you
want to push them even higher in the
latter case you want to push them even
lower so you need to at least have some
operatory sort of guess of what you
think the probability of some event is
going to be okay but we're going to
assume nothing other than that okay so
that's the minimal informational
assumption that makes sense of
extremization
we continue to assume um sort of
calibrated experts in the same sense
that we saw in the log-loss case there's
also an interesting sort of
informational substitutes type condition
uh that we impose okay which is a sort
of a topic for another talk
in any case even with all three of these
assumptions the adversary has a
tremendous amount of power in particular
uh you know they can hide from you they
can make indistinguishable whether or
not you're seeing 70 from everybody
because they all have the same evidence
or whether you're seeing 70 from
everybody because they all have
independent evidence okay the adversary
can hide that information from you so
any robustly good aggregation method has
to kind of hedge between those two
extremes and what we prove is that
externalization is
a great way to do exactly that kind of
hedging and the formal statement that we
have which shows that extermination can
be sort of provably necessary is we show
that in a sort of worst case
approximation sense worst case over the
remaining flexibility of the adversary
extremization is provably better as
provably better worst case performance
than any prior free aggregation method
you might conceivably use for example
like you know the ones we were talking
about the beginning log cooling
and linear cooling okay so with a little
bit of extra information you can make
sense of externalization and our
theoretical framework also tells you
that you're provably more powerful by
using that additional known prior
information and the way that you achieve
that
extra performance is through
extremization
all right so i think i've um wrapped up
pretty much out of time i'll leave you
with this final slide just that lists a
couple of open questions which i'm happy
to discuss in the q a um along with the
three papers from which uh this work was
drawn so i'll stop there uh thanks very
much
i have a sort of stupid question slash
comment
so
uh if you're thinking about log loss and
its unboundedness one of the techniques
that's useful in other contexts is to
mix whatever probability distribution
you were thinking about before with a
small uniform distribution over all of
your states
um and i'm curious
whether you've thought about that at all
or whether there has whether there are
some like nice consequences of doing
something like that
yeah that's a great question
um so so as jamie says often with sort
of you know
if you're like if you're implementing
kind of using a logarithmic scoring rule
in prediction market or something like
that you basically don't allow people to
report probability zero um because it
sort of messes things up you kind of
force it you sort of force a mixing in
of the uniform distribution to keep
things bound away from zero
um
i mean so i'll give an answer and then
eric feel free to chime in if there's
more you want to add
i mean in some sense
you know if you mix in any amount of the
uniform distribution it does turn log
loss into a bounded loss function
and so that first theorem does in fact
apply
uh the fine print there is that you know
the constants in the regret bound i just
emphasize the sort of dependence on
capital t as is traditional
but there's a big o of root t and in
that big o is is suppressing a constant
that depends on how much the loss
function can blow up so basically as a
function of sort of how much of the
uniform distribution you mix in
you know you'll be messing around with
the constant factor in that first
theorem
um you might hope to have kind of a
nicer interpolation between the bounded
and the unbounded cases actually eric
eric and i were just talking about that
sort of earlier earlier this week we
think that should be possible but
there's some work to do it'd be nice to
say that you know
suppose you mix in a little bit of a
uniform
you know the first theorem you know
would give you a really bad constant but
some variant of the you know some hybrid
of the two theorems would give you
something
something sort of really good so we
don't have a result like that but the
hope is that something like that would
be true
eric was there anything you wanted to
add to that
um
it's it's also the case that if you um
are coming from a perspective where you
are particularly interested
in pooling methods and you find that you
know logarithmic pooling pairs really
well with the log loss function then you
might want to ask the specific question
of how does logarithmic uh pooling do
sort of the pure question where you're
interested in assigning
weights um and so from that perspective
i find this question to be theoretically
motivated uh even if you don't
uh
have the opportunity to mix in some sort
of uniform thing
so i had a question
can you apply
like calibeding to the expert forecasts
before you put them into your
aggregation to ensure that it's
that they're calibrated and if you do
that does it
go through in a happy way
[Music]
um i'm not sure i totally eric do you
yeah so my understanding of your
question is something like look at the
prior history of those experts and then
figure out what's the right function to
apply in order for them to be calibrated
yeah
yeah there was a talk yesterday and he
alluded to this idea of calibeding where
you can
uh
basically force experts to be calibrated
and do at least as well as the expert
predictions
um i guess that for the bad uh example
where everything blows up if you have a
fully adversarial model that could
happen in the very first time step where
you have no history of
how good the experts are
so it's possible that if you have some
sort of reliable history of the experts
then indeed you can
do
pretty well um but at that point um i
would say that it's almost like you are
implicitly introducing a calibration
assumption
um by
sort of
knowing exactly how
the experts forecasts should be
manipulated and interpreted
any other questions yes we do
yeah one uh one question uh
do you know if it's possible to get fast
rates say if you assume like some
sort of x con x concavity or mixability
assumption under which of these loss
functions l you can get little
uh routine rates regret yeah that that's
a really good question like um
eric correct me if i'm wrong here but
definitely
so we certainly haven't proven any upper
bounds better than square root t
um
and
if memory serves we have lower bounds of
square root t only for restricted
families of algorithms so it's even i
think conceivable under our current set
of assumptions you could be root t is
that right eric
that's right uh in particular we have a
result that's something like
if you do omd
with a um
particular uh
with a fixed uh
step size then you cannot beat square
root of t
but in general i mean i think getting
optimal rates i probably should put that
on the open question slide here i mean i
think that's that is open and that would
be really interesting
it's conceivable you could beat the sort
of root t barrier um again as you say
maybe under some extra assumptions maybe
even not so we would be great to see
work along those lines
all right i have one question is there a
way to compare the performance of
different aggregators
uh across the different loss functions
yeah that's a good question this is
related to the question earlier about
like what if you wanted to also
choose you know what if you wanted your
learning algorithm to also choose the
aggregation method and not just the
weights
right because what we've seen here is
that like aggregation methods are kind
of tied to loss functions right so
um
i you know it feels like yeah you'd have
to decide on how to normalize right so i
mean any loss function you can apply an
athlon transformation so you can take
any pair of loss functions and kind of
make them match you know at appropriate
two points or something like this
but it's still not clear to me that it's
meaningful to compare
um
different loss functions you know in a
general way like that
um do you have thoughts eric on that
yeah it's also
um
not clear to me exactly like
i i could imagine some sort of model
where it makes sense to compare them but
like nothing nothing obvious immediately
jumps out
it feels a little like apples versus
oranges but you know what
like eric said conceivably there's a way
to address this problem but we we
haven't figured out we haven't figured
out a good approach yet
uh hi yeah my question is related to one
of those like two questions ago but if
you take the special case of like the
squared loss
with like linear aggregation like so i'm
coming from the world of like
prediction with expert advice right
where we understand how to get constant
regret
it like how much of the geometry still
matches up like at least in that special
example right where we know a lot about
like mixable losses and then here
with linear aggregator
and with uh with squared loss
um
do you think like we have
in that example do we have enough
curvature so possibly like is all we
have convexity or do we have a little
bit more
do you think because just knowing that
you have a bit more might already
suggest that you can get
uh right faster it's
that that's a good point you're even
you're even sort of suggesting the
nature of the extra assumptions you
might impose to get the fast rates right
where you kind of have some
you know basically you get second order
information um is that right or
uh so same information but just like if
the curvature of the loss carries
forward when you use like the linear
aggregator
um so like you know the composed objects
that you have
yeah so still like fully adversarial
though
yeah i don't have much i mean i i don't
have much to add i mean we
like we did not
you know on the one hand
we didn't prove anything better than
routine on the other hand i wouldn't say
that was really our focus
um and i do i do think you know i would
welcome work along those lines i think
that would definitely be interesting
eric do you have any thoughts on the
plausibility of
you know polylog or even constant or
something like that
um
what is the best you can do in just the
normal um
learning with expert advice setting um
if your
loss is squared loss
um is it square root of t or can you do
better
you get constant yeah
you can get constant
okay um
[Music]
yeah i
yeah i i don't i do not
yeah i don't know beyond convexity what
other properties can be generally
guaranteed for qa pulling
that said we didn't we didn't think
about it right i mean it there might
well be kind of some low-lying fruit
there
um it could be under you know modest
assumptions in the loss function
you know you get kind of uh
uh
you know you get the extra analytic
properties that would that would drive
sort of these faster rates that
definitely seems plausible to me
um
yeah sorry i don't mean to like uh pile
on the the constant regret questions
we've had but in the log loss case if
you decouple the experts from the
distribution so almost like the opposite
of making the calibrated assumption like
if they're uncalibrated then you also
get constant regret with linear pooling
so i'm curious about that
like
if it feels like when you don't have
them calibrated it's like an easier
problem because you're if you're
competing against bad experts that's
only good for you so i'm curious your
thoughts on that
the linear pulling part uh is really
important really in a sense we are
making our lives harder for ourselves by
choosing to do logarithmic pulling this
is motivated sort of by the fact that qa
pooling is externally uh motivated um
but um yeah basically the fact that uh
the qa pool
of
uh let's say 5050 and
some extreme forecast
is going to be extreme if you're using
uh logarithmic pooling
means that if you don't have a
calibration assumption things can go
really poorly for you so
while it is true that um if you're using
linear pulling you can do quite well
like much better than square root of t
um
if
if you're using
logarithmic pooling you in fact can't
get any positive result and need to rely
on a calibration assumption
okay
sorry uh i just have a quick question i
hope um so in
you talked about like if they're if
people are making uh predictions based
on common information then you might
want this item potency um in polling
which is like like presidential polling
uh like nate silver i uh n538 they
actually if they get the same
estimated like prediction from a bunch
of different posters they actually bias
towards 50 50 because there's like an
assumption that there's actually
correlated error right like it's not
that you're getting the same information
and so it's good it's that you're
getting the same information so they
might all be using the same wrong
information so you might want to bias
like back towards 50 50. it's like the
opposite of extremitization i'm just
curious how you guys might think about
that
it's a good question
uh so um
i think that
we would say that um the
[Music]
bias
right so because we are assuming that
the experts are calibrated
um
if the
experts know that whatever procedure
they are using will end up
with
a bias they will account for that bias
and drive back to 50 50 by themselves
and so like if the um
experts are using
the same evidence then and reporting
calibrated predictions then the right
thing for us to do
is not extremize at all
but also not to push back toward the
prior
and certainly one interesting direction
is to replace the calibration assumption
with other
restrictions
um this other kind of uh
uh you know types of modeling bias sort
of what you know how the how the
outcomes you expect to be related to the
forecasts so we we really just sort of
carried out the one because we thought
it was the most sort of natural one to
start with but
you could imagine other you know
whatever you want to call it inductive
biases or something about how the
how the outcomes sort of connect to the
forecast and that would be interesting
maybe a little bit in relation to that
um what what happens if the model if the
opponents are epsilon calibrated uh how
does that carry over yeah i was thinking
about this er erica i actually think
about this this just this morning i
think it's fine for sufficiently small
epsilon right
uh yeah
for for the results concerning
extremization i assume so uh regarding
uh the logarithmic pooling results since
the regions around zero and one are
particularly sensitive you might want
some sort of like multiplicative
or like uh an epsilon
uh plus or minus epsilon to be added to
like the log odds
instead of the actual probability
um so that uh an epsilon probability
can't actually mean a zero probability
or vice versa
right so so for a suitable notion of
approximately calibrated right it would
the log loss results would carry through
right
i think so yeah
okay
uh thank you so much uh tim and eric
clearly you got us very excited with
your talk
a lot of questions uh a big round of
applause again
all
right thanks everybody very happy to
participate wish i could be there so
have a good